Trey Wingo here on the Rich Eisen show
hello rich did you hate that house band
as much as I hated that house band last
ah there were some questionable choices
well I mean I'm just don't know how loud
they were yes dreaming over them - yes I
was a lot actually I was having a
problem with the band yeah you know it's
just you know you and I we have a tough
job to do there's so much happening yeah
people don't know they're slate spinning
this goes on it's what you refer to as
plate spinning Iowa's for the old Steve
Martin line juggling flaming cats right
just long enough so you don't burn your
hands and keep things moving right
that's what it is because I mean you've
got all these people that you need to
get in for the analysts and they're
probably in your ear saying you got this
graphic take this do this it's not it's
not it's not a it's easily the toughest
thing I have I totally agree with you
the thing in you and I've been very
fortunate do a lot of things a lot over
all over a lot of years yes the draft by
far is the most time-consuming pulling
you in eight different directions at one
time than I can ever think of but
there's in all the places that we've
been fortunate to do it this was amazing
it was incredible I mean cuz you were
facing that you I think you might have
had a maybe a better angle looking up
Broadway than we did from where we were
cuz not much well we had this monster
whatever VIP setup that right that was
right in front of us right what a scene
that is it's unbelievable when I kept
seeing the shot of the drone camera
going down right I was like where does
it Kentucky we looked at the numbers of
Nashville I think it was a the Greater
Metro area was 1.7 million I think they
were all on Broadway last night it was
we said as funny I'd like to get your
take on this we thought going into the
night that Philadelphia experience was
once the greatest but we'd seen on the
outdoor sure right yeah and then when we
got to the stage at Nashville we looked
at each other and we said you know I
killed all these in the lead by one
stroke in the clubhouse but Nashville is
tiger who just turned a 29 on the front
side you know he's coming in hot yeah
and I have to say I think that was um
that was the best draft
arians I've ever seriously I know and
would not even close well the reason why
Philly was was was in the clubhouse is
because they created a draft hall out of
thin air right whereas Grant Park is at
least a park with a huge space yes like
this one they created out of the Rockies
they actually literally had to move the
rocky statue in a way so they could
create the draft Hall yeah this one is
already ready-made party spot they drop
the draft in - yeah and the other thing
about Philly let's be honest we all
would have failed a drug test after that
the contact high coming in from the
parking lot was like you guys are really
enjoying this dress well and that was
speaking somebody who's broadcasting
from a lot of places yeah that was the
Tiger shooting at twenty nine coming in
hot
taking the black hole Oakland Raiders
parking lot of the class one stroke
leader yeah I'm at the part I'm glad we
didn't snow one said here here's a cup
we need to handle some business after
that one that was that was interesting
as the poll question of great Wingo here
Chris Brockman while we have Trey here
normally when Brock and I are talking
it's about Game of Thrones sport well
not it's used spoiling things at 6:01
Eastern hey man Twitter's an
instantaneous reaction get off it far
fewer by the way no thank you
he has no leg to stand on Trey he came
on the air on Monday and he goes well
nobody died last night and he's like
it's not a spoiler because nobody died
I'm like what if somebody told you that
before you tuned in to this show her med
words one week when he was doing the
radio with us he goes listen I'm gonna
leave but I got one spoiler one little
thing it's not a little thing goes bad
guys got a dragon
we're like I'm just glad herm is locked
in most head-scratching move of the
first round biggest head-scratching move
farewell the Raiders of four giants
taking Jones at six the Cardinals not
trading Josh Rosen Haskins all the way
to 15 well I think I think Rosen's gonna
go tonight and probably for second round
pink I think that's gonna happen tonight
so that's not so surprising that would
be a dream for Steve karma yes second I
think either Pharrell or hat Daniel
Jones because what did what did Dave
gentlemen always say the general manager
I'm not going to reach for
player and we reach for a player and
look if it works out that he's the next
whatever then fine but you know it so as
you know when we always talk about this
it's it's not only about the players
about the value of the pick could you
have used that pick at six to get more
capital and still gotten Daniel Jones I
think the answer might have been yes I
think so
you know sir although at four we were
like John what are you doing well it's
not John it was I think it's John and
Mayock and the reason what I said
earlier is I'm like if if Mayock had
been saying that from his draft spot
position right the last fifteen years
right and somebody doesn't take feral
people would be like Mayock told you to
take fro why would you do that you know
now that he's actually doing that
without the two months of him saying it
is it build-up people wondering what the
hell's your problem yeah you know it
just depends on whether you thought
furrow
or Josh Allen was the best guy off the
edge right I think that was a 50/50
split on okay who's on your set tonight
we're trading a booger for a mache so
buh-buh-buh Garland's out the chaise
exactly boogers going over to the
gameday side and talking chests it'll be
me Mel Todd and Louis and same set for
you with Daniel never know it's me and
Daniel Curt left because he's a Hall of
Famer and he has to go he tackled
sometimes that's that's happened to us
all went back to Stanford
how dare he goes throw the Charles Davis
comes in and and so does Joel Klein by
the way I was just talking to Joel he's
good Lovejoy and Daniels so great by the
way you know he he worked for us for a
few years I'm so happy that he's got
that fly the man he he's awesome yeah I
don't know move the sticks check him out
on Twitter by the way I've got 50
seconds left unfortunately that was a
blast being on with you and Reese it was
it was a lot of fun yeah we the three of
us together because we all sort of you
wouldn't you get there 96 yeah 95 I was
96 and I was a 97 so when they reran
those photographs
Driss went first then i went second you
went third on the montage that they
showed it was embarrassing
Greece's hair is still the same ours
let's say is not he's Benjamin Button
yes he is
he has aged backwards and we have just
oh a j-- that's what it is when you're
in LA next week coming
done absolutely both my kids live out
there now so I'm feeling being there
more often absolutely it's amazing
that's crazy I like that you're the man
brother Thank You Trey Wingo rich I
thank you Chris Brockman so listen to
wing go with Golic every single day and
also all check him out on ESPN tonight
and you were there Saturday - yes sir
we'll be here all day we'll be here all
day for more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app